[Music]
hey what's up Samuel Leeds here and this
week we have another success story from
Scotland his name is Simon Hayter and
Simon is making around about twelve
thousand pounds a month in deal sourcing
and also two thousand eight hundred
pound a month in income like from rents
and stuff absolutely killing it so
welcome to the show Simon how you doing
okay Sonya thank you I really appreciate
you coming down all the way from
Scotland although you do drive down to
the Midlands quite a lot from Scotland
yes the tower to crash course is quite
often yeah and so I'm tutoring the
Midlands of England quite well to go
with a crash course would not be a crash
course without you in the audience
because I mean this year I've been
focusing quite a lot because crash
courses are not just about going once a
ten Lennon what you're learning and
going away and trying to apply it for
the rest of your life it's also about
trying to keep up to date with what's
happening what you teach as well and how
have changes in the market are gonna
affect you as as a property investor and
when did you first decide I mean how did
you even get so I used to be a subway
franchisee I was a pre franchisee for
six years and I was in the process of
selling my business on to someone else
and I got thinking about what would go
do for the future your job what would
you after the subway business because
that was the only thing I had and then I
just came across property as as I would
drop shipping and I would say Amazon FBA
and all that stuff and then you one of
your videos popped up and start looking
at property and then start watching I
think it was the the video first when I
saw was the video of you in the car at
Christmas Day I think it was that was
that was the first one and you were just
giving a message about about property
investing and and and what to look for
going ahead in the future and stuff so
that was kind of when I start watching
the rest of your video
and then from there I thought you know
well the crash course is free so I'm not
going to leave any worse off ethical so
that's my big the crash course for
November of last year so literally what
like yes but five six five six months
ago yeah yeah okay so you came on the
crash course did you have any experience
in property or knowledge of property
provide to that well from my youtube
videos that having a lot of bit of
knowledge when I was younger but because
I had watched for a couple of months for
a puppet developer my was like sixteen
but that's there's no Ralphs experience
so you know pretty rookie novice to the
property world yeah and it's also cuz
the fact that a lot of people as what
you just spell as well at a crash course
but a lot of people think about property
as this colossal industry that you need
a fortune to get end to and start and
start off with you don't need to eat
like you know two hundred thousand pound
in the bank itself alone so that's why a
lot of people that's why it kind of
initially I didn't go down that route
where was younger you know if I was if I
knew back then what I know now then you
know what God knows where we been yeah
just turned 31 you it was in Manchester
that was I think was the last small one
you were doing before you start off with
the bigger venues and the you're just
teaching us obviously how to search for
properties how to work out you know
another why the basic stuff that you
would normally do doesn't my refuge in
the crash course so you were actually
just a plain passion off the street just
looking to buy a buy to our investment
and so you were teaching all that all
the basic stuff that you need to know
and it just kind of the the reason that
you're teaching in insuring us how to
invest in property just means the
numbers slack up a lot more and just
meet that opportunity is a lot better
then as you say you go to the agent
blindfolded and just pick a random
property off of the windows so that's
gonna really start a tenancy I mean
actions and one of my business partners
I've done one I rent two rents I met
Hammond there as well and so the DfE as
well so not my partner no no thank you I
don't the crash cause joint ventures the
joint ventures are good because like you
know you might be shearing that the
profit end of the day but you're sharing
the journey you're sharing experience
and you're also sharing the ideas and
the creativity you have so I think it's
worse that's an investment offense then
it's not also someone says it's not what
you know it's who you know other things
that it's both and I think you get both
at the crash course you get the
knowledge but you also get the network
and meet a lot of people so what
happened then when you left the crash
course I know you went to the deal for
anything extravagant what happened there
dear fee so it was basically I hadn't
image in my head that the DfE was
something about going to the next stage
in terms of learning brand-new stuff but
actually it's not an in a way it's
actually good that it's not because it
means that the crash course was you know
you do for free is adding so much value
in content at the very beginning and
it's giving you the basic skills to do
the property to the proper investment
and then you're the DfE is enhancing
knows that's homing them it's working
with other people in the room you know I
think Kevin but how many people were
there I was like ya know 500 people some
like that so I was you're networking
with a whole bunch of people from
different walks of life different stages
as well in the property journey so it
was as Bessie is is try to build on your
skills that you developed from the crash
course but also implementing your own
skills that you've learned before and
bringing them together I think that's
great and did you book a load of
viewings and I mean how did that how did
you go from having no property
experience yeah part from two months
working for a developer when you're 16
yeah just suddenly within a matter of
five or six months yeah you can
financially free yeah making 12
and a month on top of your property
income deal sourcing so I didn't pick a
lot of viewings because I wanted to do
two things I wanted to look at the
Scotland market and particular so I
think because there's different
launching the legal changes regulation
and stuff that's the thing that kind of
needed a bit more effort and time what
the do well HMO licensing for example
you know you'd always need a license and
Scotland compared to an England whereas
the article four so although a local
force being roll roll is rolling out
it's going it's a blanket so it's
something that that's a big massive
change when you're looking for each more
profits for example but you're looking
for a below market value so it's hard
it's hard in Scotland not impossible but
say it harder because the fact that and
Scotland you always need a home report
for any property that you're looking to
sell whereas in an England a service
then she is optional if the buyer is
wanting one or not sure I always would
recommend you get a survey so that's two
examples of the complete difference
between Scotland market and hugely no so
Hugh knows what you do often in England
anyway yeah and then a server you need
to get in Scotland which you should
really be doing anyway yes yes it's
usually different but was the fact that
the I knew had Nestle wasn't the stage
where I want to go buy my first bite
there ya know I kind of wanted to go
down the sourcing route and I wait to
say that at the DfE III had my original
plan the DfE was to get my first buy a
bite slit yeah that was my plan changed
kaput yeah because we had the
conversation at the DFA yes and because
of the DfE it's more you kind of walk
away with a game plan really don't ya
yes I was at the crash course across
course it's just like here are all the
things you can do
yeah where the DfE it's like fine-tuning
that and actually bending your path
that's where path to the start of you
call a property journey and that's what
the DfE allows you to do because it
allows you to
decide what fits best for you what
skills you have join the Academy no not
yet but it will be a continual B I'll
continue a conversation retro oh joy the
last three months to join tomb I would
see two months be generous to survive
but but I mean the Academy you don't
need to go on the Academy to be
successful I know you will join there
well yeah yeah I mean I could be not
that I'm Sarah I'm because I have
definite not but I could be as
successful as you I was stolen in the
Academy yeah because it's again the
Academy adds or not extra layer of
homing your skills your network your
value you can add to your own property
business and that's what they kind of
your brings because you're on that same
level as everyone else it's even for the
same thing and obviously the network
that you could pervade as well so that's
what Academy does as well I think it's
just timing isn't it yeah me I will join
I will join me okay I can promise right
now I will be joining the Academy but
I'm just really happy to see that you
know you're being successful as a result
of the free training and the DFA is fine
it's fantastic to see so you decided not
to be a property investor only but you
wanted to be a property entrepreneur
basically yeah which is someone rent to
rent the old packaging serviced
accommodation so what was your first
deal my first deal was it was a rent ACN
Manchester yeah and it was and media say
thanks for me to say it's offered that
was the first way and actually that I
started off looking at that the DfE
actually and then I booked a viewing I
think it was the was face a couple days
after the DfE so I traveled back home to
ellebra back turned to Manchester
purpose companies after and then only
took about a week we are to literally
say in the paper work and process that's
right
doing good it's doing good were your
first year your that's quite weird when
you're trying to set it up you're always
second-guessing
yourself is like that salad good the air
or so the right color or or it's your
I'm happy with that and that could be
better
you think you spending a fortune and
forever trying to get it perfect it yeah
and you are a quick little and early on
that that's the worst thing you could do
is the best thing you do is to get to
the free remains of what your customers
expectation is going to be and just
meter if you meet customers expectation
then you're always going to be on a
one-hour so that's what quicker dead so
that's great so you got your service
accommodation in just what happened next
then I started looking at the deal
sourcing process so I ordered actually
first of all the DfE we got asters
compliance book so the the yellow book
that we we go through yeah I mean the
compliance part of it you know it was
sort of so important that every deal
sorcerer does and then from the Erebor
Alice's book and I read that and that
kind of includes that part but it it
talks about his journey and and how he
became a a deal sorcerer and it's
skeptical scott as well and then no
ideally he's a very typical skeptical
scotsman as we say you know because all
these people they're not at the crash
course it's high-energy and we you know
high-five each other and things like
that there's a real energy and sometimes
when people come from Scotland they're
not used to necessarily that kind of
energy how did you find that I think I'd
be fair to see a lot of people from
Scotland I've pretty much set in their
ways
yeah and it's it's not as soon as you
break that mold it's when they open
their manes and I think that's a fair
characterization because that's exactly
why I was they set your reason of how
the world works or what the possibility
of opportunities are available and in
fact actually if you proactively look
for the opportunities instead of the
opportunities magically coming to you
then you find them yeah
we do that is you know to open people's
mind also and you've got like a 12 14
hour a day if it was a slideshow for 14
hours people would fall asleep so we get
people doing things and bringing us
their agents and finding deals and in
order to get results but also to keep
people active and engaged so how much
money make it on that Manchester
property Manchester one that one I'm
doing just 800-900 it feels quite a long
time in court but wasn't money wise that
I got that through a sorcerer so it's a
first where so there was a sourcing via
paid for that and then the initial
investments or and oh no it came to
about 10,000 that put into that so it's
quite a hefty chunk oh yeah it's quite a
hefty amount but then where else can you
put down ten thousand pounds and then my
aunt in Japan among correct and then boy
you work out how much going to be
bringing back over the duration of the
the length of the event to rent then you
want you're going to get that back in
your profit anyway so I don't want as
bruh so far okay so the edible market is
fair to see the edible markets the
biggest @sc service competition sorry
mark I've said one done yeah well
Edinburgh I believe is the number one
place for serviced accommodation in the
whole of the UK
really I believe it's definitely hard
again - yeah especially when contact and
landlords HSB to them yes yeah chair
thinks the sitting the concept of rent
or able to see renter in because if
start going down that road is you spend
about half an hour trying to explain
well as you go down the row of
corporates
etc etc the start the start considering
it and then you
you didn't get to the brass tacks
numbers and often the very first
question I'd get is so how much should
we pay here and rent then and of course
then you know I'm saying well you're
asking 800 pound I'm going to give you a
hatch apparent but it often is the
expect that you're offered to be higher
than what they're asking for which is
very strange
it's something I've discovered it seems
to be only an Oedipus because they know
the lien of the market they know how
lucrative yes combination is why
wouldn't they just do it themselves
so after speaking with some of the some
landlords initially when I started it
was very much it was a hassle yeah my
managing at all because the edibles are
busy you know if you take August for
example Oedipa doubles and population
just in one month yeah you know you're
talking about close to 700,000 people
between you know August to the middle of
September
and of course that month so the the it's
clearly busy so and the rest of the year
is felt up quite well as well for most
for more service completion so the
hassle that they do for long ones doing
short wets and a long time later just
don't want go imagination what you're
doing is you're giving the landlord what
he wants yeah then you're turning the
property from a normal apartment to a
serviced accommodation hotel yeah I mean
the thing is the way I put it to
language which seems to be actually
breaking ice more is because I played
about with the terminology have taught
them is this is how I could bet this is
how this benefits you and you list all
the reasons and one of the biggest
things is time management
you know because you offer them
essentially to lower the cost increase
the profit margin because you're taking
over the maintenance of the property so
they don't have to spend that you know
you're you're giving them guaranteed
rent for the duration of the period so
there's no void periods so they're
saving money on that and you're also
then margin property they don't need to
do it so you've got if you get a five
year went
the contract for example that's five
years they don't have to do anything
yeah exactly so essentially you're going
to as soon as you go to them explain to
them how this saves their money door
don't talk about how how it'll benefit
you as you taking over the property talk
to them about how it's actually going to
benefit in business that's always the
first thing what's in it for me so how
much you make it on your head in Borough
serviced accommodation that's just over
a thousand yeah that's to start at and
how much did you put down to secure it
in total Oh - laughs grand
two-and-a-half grand so your first deal
you put down ten grand yeah and you make
an 800 but then as you got better your
second deal you put down two and a half
grand and between that has been me set
up my own deals awesome yeah because I
know how to do it making over a grand a
month yeah from just two and a half
grand most people would say that's not
possible
well they need to go to the crash cross
then that I just see I've been the three
so far for shortly and as possible and
you we go to a crash course somebody
says that or people watching this yes
the back is I can see how do you say
that's impossible
you can't do that because the fact that
in a society we've always been a special
school we've been told that you know you
work so hard for your for the rest of
your life and see the small amount for
your pension and you then that split be
the good life but you struggle and
struggle at that point and and I pass
you don't see why people put money in
pensions because then they feel
improperly you're better off for the
bench it's burst my personal preference
I think we elastically if you google
crash course it's free other than your
travel expenses listen to what goes on
how it works if it make sense to you
give it a go I I was I was still
skeptical even though I went and bought
the the to go on the DfE yeah I've still
kept all of to that you know I was at
Kenneth's again a whole there's people
the hope is pleased off
but if it doesn't then you know he
started some of us need to feint
something else but I gave it that sharp
and that investment
he wrote goes and and it doesn't make
sense yeah so you're making about 12,000
pound a month is that right I'm deal
sourcing yeah yeah and as incredible I
mean wait
there's a huge amount money I mean I
having a subway store for six years I
was you I was turning over about twelve
thirteen thousand a month anyway so it I
know what since we shiver but it's kind
of like a replacement Kenner was doing
before I know that's the thing that was
Dave's turnover and what you and my
profit for this is like eighty five
ninety percent because that's a joint
event is pain and the skills that you've
put into sourcing a property for
somebody I mean I was probably doing
about name ten percent but a bit more
than that yeah I just spent over a grand
yeah and a fraction of the effort yeah I
mean this is so hard work because they
you're you're speaking to those are
people all week deal sourcing it's not
just about I know people think that
you're you just go on Rightmove or soup
or whatever and find a property and do
an ROI and then telling somebody it's
it's a capacitor that's just stage one
stage two as what we do is we package it
together so we make sure the numbers
make sense we do parables we do be
evidence-based exactly pretty much what
else the teachers as well and then we
then at the same time is this is all
going on we're making sure that the
numbers stack up but the property make
sense and the laces and if we need to
can get achieved in that area etcetera
etcetera so you take what we're doing is
it will try to build a vessel
you know so we've we've currently gone
over the 500 mark of esters on our
mailing list and we're pulling out we've
actually tried to pull out a vessels are
physically ready to invest now and then
we we do a search and process for them
so we can get them a property as soon as
possible
and sometimes we find in properties and
the fad properties that have fell fell
through for clients and it happens it's
gutting when it does but you know I just
apologized to the client and then I say
you were we're focusing our effort on
you right now and just you to get you
sorted and and get you back on track and
then just remain service always is about
how you deal with the problem yes how's
your general life I mean it must be
quite a life changing thing that's
happened yeah last year was I mean last
year was quite brutal I mean I mean I
went from having well her to go back to
it it's not just the past six months
it's been probably the last year and a
half as Carol went through quite a lot
because I went from so I stood for
election there dobrze I lost obviously
but it was good experience
I've definitely consider doing it again
I've been campaign for for 15 16 years
and politics or used to it and then lost
our and then you know broke up with a
long-term partner for almost nine years
and then kind of went through all
transformation and lost about four now
stone and quite short period of time so
the business as well and then obviously
then from there and also start looking
at property so the whole killer last
12-18 months has been quite iOpener
transformational perhaps but I don't
know yeah yeah every lost ship so what's
next in for you
my main focus deaf is to build property
the property sourcing business the brand
I wanted to build an investor's list I
want to to make it much more make you
stronger get out there more to do to set
up more joint ventures for people as
well and more event at red de assis of
course because they're always good to
have more of what we're doing but thing
is it's not just more what I'm doing
because every single thing every cent
every single new property seems to be
always bigger or it's more complex but
when we have to deal with complexity or
it's about trying to go for a bigger
fish or a salsa cause a wheel trying to
a bigger wheel now got a handful of red
to rent you're selling deals what's your
strongest reason why it's a fashio
freedom that has to be why because the
financial freedom allows you to then do
what is you want to do you know it
allows you to to wake up one morning and
say you know let's go let's go away for
a week yeah but you can walk away you
you know the beauty of properties and
property investing as well especially
sourcing as well as you could do
anywhere in the world you know that
especially your freedom challenge first
one being in the beach getting the
Perkins coming in so is you could do
remotely is it's one of the very few
businesses you can do that and that's
that that's perhaps probably equally as
important as everything else do it well
properly invest then is that is that
flexibility and the freedom to do that
luckily for you you've got the
experience have been able to have your
subway business
yes we're running and you can compare
the two a lot of people that going to
property they don't know what to compare
it to but I think the property investing
or being a property entrepreneur it's
just one of the best businesses you know
the the time freedom it gives you the
fact that you can work anywhere it's
just a fantastic business and absolutely
yeah I'm used to that because the subway
business was a feeling business when I
bought it it was hemorrhaging money it
was losing one
was run down I take it took me that that
five four or five years to build that to
build it back up after already gone for
about nine years
so so I mean it was the first business I
had and I bought I was a still at
university when I actually bought her
and then I can anything that has gone
wrong in business did go wrong during
the pure period but actually it's
probably mainly better suited now to go
into property and how to deal with
difficult situations yeah or how to how
to chop on somebody's door you know that
may be a multi-millionaire and you're
trying to sign them as a client you know
or to you go for no you're not take
what's your answer
the hardest challenge it's definitely
been making sure that each property deal
you put together makes sense
yeah not just you but even make sense
for your investor what do you mean what
make sense a decent week it's not just
about the numbers it needs to make meet
their expectations because every single
vest are that I've dealt with in the
past I probably ball in the future and
currently going through and looking
properties right now for them they're
all got different expectations of what
kind of property they're looking for or
you know they want a certain way in and
and I understand that and the hardest
thing is to make sure that you meet your
clients a plication that is the hardest
part and if you do that then it actually
helps you balance and you dealt with any
crazy investors or ending the horror
stories no I think I've been lucky not
to have a I probably probably give you a
six months over here I already good I
mean an adorable key causes of crash
courses because the crash courses as the
foundation we talked about we're talking
about property investor the crash
courses
Foundation the fair teachers need to be
there to always be there so why not go
to the crash course why not keep going
back you know and the coin if anything
the contact she built up and the
networking create just by going to crash
course you meet people who are your
builders contractors lawyers doctors ste
Egypt's the best ones a whole bunch of
other people students you know there's
this give you perfect sample there's
this there's this guy who's 17 if I'd
imagine some technical he is eager to
get properly and obviously if you're 17
years old he's he's bring a property to
me to walk west go through examples for
having to learn how to search property
and to get em to ready for when he's is
new heads eighty mark and trying to get
the property so we've been working with
them for the past well but see four
weeks maybe longer I don't know see
quite well and the every single time
were going through properties he's
brought us he he's learning something
new but direct them to light we and he's
fine he's fine his feet and you know
she's deals come through with him you
know we sell reseller for forum enemies
to be split a defense that's right
I saw Stroud to give back as well and I
think in the property industry you'll
find that that people tend to want
everyone shares one another one more
thing yeah in most businesses people see
each other's competition
whereas in property business certainly
how I see everyone's collaborating and
cheerily to the wrong which i think is
fantastic
yeah because the fact is like the more
we help each other the more successful
each of people become but I mean there's
people that should start off so they are
you further behind in the journey I am
but there's people that so I am
positioned to help them but as people
are further than the journey ahead to me
you know and and I hope that they would
have be able to help me when I ever when
I have problems and I have had tour
problems I messaged you I've spoke to
Paul as well message power few times we
have gone
we've had questions and he's been quite
helpful
Alistair as well a whole bunch of people
Courtney from the office you know saw
the network he'd be Power Team that you
bailed just by doing this as you know
start off the crash course doing the DfE
even going to the Academy one at some
point going through this the property
journey probably less then there are
someone around yeah that can help you
don't know you know the answer just
someone else so what advice would you
give to someone that's watching this
that really wants to kill it in property
step one crash course step two as
YouTube is definitely a good resource
then get onto DfE is therefore a must
and then from there find out what it is
you want don't just go ahead and think
you're oh I want to I get property but
I've got no money I'll get a property
first I'll try to figure out with the
money is you could do that ever walks
off great fantastic but for me my advice
would be is definitely to look at all
the different paths into property
investing and pick which one's best for
you and apply yourself to that and do
what perseverance yeah
and the very beginning the first couple
of weeks we get into prop resourcing I
mean the amount of hours of spending
these I was spending doing this trying
to find the first deal or trying to
throw first investor to sell to and
start off a multiple website and all
this stuff you need perseverance and
self motivation you've got those two
things that's 50% of the bowel wish you
all the best
I look forward to hopefully one by
having you on the Academy I promise I
will be on the Academy I promise I'll
Batman thank you
my name's Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your in spray
you can watch more right here on the
playlist as a whole playlist of them but
what you'll notice is every single
winner on a Wednesday always starts with
them coming to my two day crash course
so if you would like to be a winner on a
Wednesday literally come on my crash
course and who knows in three months
time you could be here in my offices on
this show as a winner on a Wednesday so
get yourself booked on the crash course
watch more have fun I'll see you next
week